he's my spider-man so it's like you know
i i would practice his lines in the
mirror when i was in drama school like i
was very high at the time
andrew garfield has an unconventional
way of manifesting his dreams oh my
goodness of course yeah entirely yeah
the actor paid a visit to the graham
norton show and talked all about his
iconic no way home cameo with his two
spidey bros toby mcguire and tom holland
i'm far too old to be playing spider-man
now but they they asked me back and and
it's the sweetest thing ever and tom
holland is just the best so i just kind
of became a fan again and then and then
they asked me to do it and and toby was
doing it as well it's toby i've got to
do it toby's doing it and that's when
andrew admits he's a long time toby
super fan i would practice his lines in
the mirror when i was at drama school
who am i
i'm spider-man
as andrew confesses i was very high at
the time he also reveals his friends
weren't exactly buying his technique my
friend terry mcginnis who and he would
he would crack up and he would look at
me like yeah you'll never play
spider-man andy and uh and then and then
here we are and uh
you know what it is i love about being
spider-man
everything of course andy went on to
become toby's successor in the amazing
spider-man film franchise and things
came full circle when toby and andrew
pulled off the epic surprise cameo of
cameos in the latest spider-man
installment no way home
everyone loves it everyone allowed them
spider-man yeah
this is insane it's a great day in my
life it's cool man it's a rare thing the
38 year old actor was tight-lipped on
the secret four months he even lied to
e.t about it more than once there's a
lot of chatter of the is he or isn't he
when it comes to the next spider-man
so let me just ask i know what you were
getting asked then i was like is he
originally like what's the where's this
going well where is it going how do you
tell me oh boy
listen what people are talking about
is a really cool idea and and and again
i haven't received a phone call but he
even kept his spider-man love interest
and real-life ex-girlfriend emma stone
in the dark
emma kept on texting me and she was like
are you in this new spider-man film
and i was like
i don't know what you're talking about
to the end you've never admitted to emma
no and then she and then she saw it
she's like you're a jerk so who was let
in on the secret my dad my brother okay
um and my and my mother at the time and
yeah just just kind of us but andrew's
sneaky ways continued even after the
film was released i snuck into a theater
one like on opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on my mask and just kind of
like
and uh in fact i was actually with toby
me and toby snuck into a theater
together
no one knew we were there now that the
secret's out of the bag it's clear to
see the spider-man brotherhood is so
real the fact that i get to be one of
those people wearing the suit next to my
actual spider-man hero toby maguire and
the the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spider-man of tom holland and
then i get to be the middle brother and
i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother and we were just
there to kind of support and have a lot
of fun and it was so much
goddamn fun
[Music]